hey guys this is des the founder fake
kara and this is Ralph from IGN
entertainment and this is our review of
the game of thrones season 3 finale no
are you sad 10 more months to your eyes
yeah that's a long time to wait a lot
that happened this week even though most
of it was kind of Chatty the title of
the episode is a misa right mother which
we you know the ending let's talk about
ending first we see the whole Danny sing
the whole like religious figure of what
Danny is turning into no she's she's a
liberator right now I'm like it and I
love Danny's title because it's just
always ever longer you know what I mean
it's Daenerys Stormborn mother of
dragons liberator you know that and it
just keeps getting longer and longer
more and more wonderful and we wish we
could all learn that earn that many sort
of titles to trail against our name
mm-hmm um but it is it is an interesting
thing right because like particularly ie
we knew that that if you've read the
books you knew that that moment was
going to happen because of the title of
the episode but when you see it visually
like that in her in the blue against all
the brown clothing and things like that
it does feel like this religious figure
yeah what do you think about that mean
what do you think about her becoming an
object of worship um well I haven't read
the books I didn't know is calling but
when it happened I felt like I think
this is great as long as in the future
episodes they show the downside and and
the problems with with such a revered
and religious figure if they start
showing like wow she can't please
everyone and all these things that
happen to her but if it becomes like oh
no she is that you know that high like
perfect being than no I'm not interested
in that but I don't think that's gonna
happen this game of thrones exactly this
I was just gonna say that this is Game
of Thrones and really nobody is perfect
and I think that's one of the strengths
certainly of the the books and the
characters in the books and the show as
well as that very few people are pure
villains very few people are purely good
there is new on sin everyone I would say
of course Joffrey I mean if a couple new
villains now as well but really Joffrey
to date has been the one that is
and purely evil and awful now we've got
swinging back to the beginning of the
episode certainly we have a couple new
contenders in Russa Roose Bolton and and
mr. ass will fray yeah I mean that you
know the aftermath of the red wedding
with you know was in the beginning and
you know the only thing I could think
especially you know when already had to
see Rob's body being paraded around with
yeah like they call it um Rob wind or
gray Rob wind um what they did how they
have they defiled his body and that was
a mirror to what happened remember
Joffrey made Sansa look at Ned's yeah
yeah head on a spike it was this it's so
defiling it yes no it's the lowest of
the low I mean is you can't you can't do
anything lower hmm and it was great when
brands sort of called back to what they
had done and said the gods didn't punish
him because the cook yeah I'm the rock
cook God's didn't punish him because he
committed murder they punished him
because he killed a guest under his roof
and that is unforgivable not knowing
what had happened I thought that was a
great call back to what they had done
yeah and man how much I mean I feel so
like bad for aria but she's such a
badass character she's one of my
favorites we turned to each other dennis
and i turned to each other during the
Aria scene when she was having I mean
first of all let's just talk about that
opening sequence the brutality the pure
brutality of the way that they were
slaying cutting off people's legs
hanging them from trees it was so
animalistic and then when you see Rob
Aria pardon me having to witness this we
just heard of each other and were like
man this girl's life yeah just awful I
mean she saw her father yet his head cut
off a father who she loves so much and
then now this like no she is she's gonna
be turned into cold blood assessing
she's gonna like kill mofos just like
she did in this episode I mean arias
talked about wanting to do those things
before but he or she is and this is the
first time she really didn't is because
it's the person that did that decimated
her brother's body moves something very
poetic about that very of course brutal
and dark I love the hounds respond I
love that he had to go through the fire
with which he was afraid of to get her
out and I love the hounds response
because you know she's had these
different parents a mental figures and
sort of guides along the way and it's
just like well if you're gonna do that
tell me about it yeah well he doesn't
really care he's like I could kill these
guys anyways but just let me know yeah
so like we'll just tell me you know if
you're gonna be out all night it was a
it wasn't funny but there was something
oddly yeah they have a cool dynamically
like she wants to kill him but the same
time he kind of wants to protect her
because remember at this point he has no
financial motivation anymore I take care
of her before he was under the guise of
oh I'm gonna get money for you whenever
now that's gone but yeah he's still
protects her yeah and again it's a game
of thrones i think has this wonderful
way of creating these fascinating
relationships between people that should
be and our enemies and yet are thrown
together and come to an understanding
with one another so wasn't in the books
but certainly it was in the show are in
tywyn you know she was never gonna like
him but it was an interesting dynamic
between the two of them now re in the
hound it has a little more potential to
get past Amity though i don't know i
mean she's she's she's not the forgiving
sort as we've seen you know and then of
course we have jaime and brienne you
know sort of beginning with this md and
coming and they really really have come
to a an intimacy an emotional intimacy
with one another yeah and and further
wrong with the you know Roose Bolton and
holden fri we see that scene and it's
kind of revealed I mean I got this
spoiled before in the comments someone I
think someone told me or something like
that that his bastard son Ramsay snow is
the one that's torturing Theon and the
whole reasoning of how you know if you
remember Rob said aloud bolton to send
his bastard son to take Winterfell back
right and it's funny because it's one of
the things that we've been saying the
season is basically you know if you want
to know who's torturing Theon just think
back to season two and you
remember who was sent to handle it you
know and that's who it is you know like
they said who it is but here we are we
have the reveal he's bananas he oh yeah
cray cray oh you have that whole scene
with the sausage and like you know oh
man as a guy you're just like looking at
going oh no it's so like you like
cringing at it and and how about them
sending the actual favorite toy to Balon
Greyjoy what I will say that that
yielded I mean cut I roni obvious I was
not obviously a fan of baylin's anyway
yeah um but it's really interesting
because Tywin who also is very ruthless
as we know you know gives this whole
speech this gorgeous speech in a way um
about how important he he under he does
have a code of ethics and it's about his
family but that means the name not like
I love you soon clearly but is about the
name and I hope upholding the name and
bettering the name of Lannister you know
I'm putting them in a better better
position politically speaking um and yet
Greyjoy has no heat like do you think
for a second the Tywin Lannister would
let that continue to happen to one of
his sons no because it makes him look
weak yes that's why what I loved about
that is that Yara ecstatic you know with
her brother was like no I've made my
decision and this is what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go get my baby brother and
this is how yeah she you can tell you
can see like the love that she still has
for her little brother even though they
haven't really seen or they didn't see
each other for many many years and and
you know they you know she's this high
commander and he's just like this almost
like a spoiled guy me kind of got
spoiled by being with the Stars oh sure
I mean he look I was a fan of his and he
made a lot of mistakes but I think
especially when you see this torture
play out you think okay enough yo you
get some sympathy for him yeah because
it's hard to say that because he did
yeah other than all the terrible other
things he did he did
cold-bloodedly till you see children
that is true and so it's hard to say
enough but at some point just kill the
man yeah just kill him put him out of
his misery man this is so cruel what's
happening to him but it does sort of
make you question things about how far
we how far is too far introduced
punishing people but I mean one of the
bigger themes of this this episode was
family and she certainly is the sister I
would want to have yeah that was a
really cool seen her like I'm you know
I'm in my to say I'm gonna take the ship
and take all these people and I'm gonna
go get him yeah yeah and then speaking
of Brandon that story um they they run
into a Sam Sam well yes yes very very
conveniently um well yeah yes and I
think that what was really key and
important about that besides brand being
able to get to the north and and again
another big theme in this episode is
that we understand that the real threat
is coming from the army of the undead
and the White Walkers I mean that's the
real threat it's it's really not as
Melisandre even said it's not about this
war of five Kings it's about this other
much larger much more dangerous war and
so we get that and he kept the dryer you
last thank God I thought he'd dropped it
ya know maybe he just had more than we
thought I think maybe just used one up
or something like yeah I think he had
more than we thought and so think and I
do remember I guess him collecting more
than that but thank God and now they
understand what it is and they're sort
of armed with it we still on the show we
don't know why bran has to go there but
we know that he understands that he does
and then he's some kind of key and all
of this I mean that's the other thing is
like where we keep being told who's a
key he's a key figure in all this and
and they are key figures in different
ways he's kind of like a special figure
like Harry Potter's well I mean he's got
he's got these very unique and powerful
abilities now armed with the only thing
that we know of that can kill the army
of the undead how that plays out we will
see ya
he's got Hodor on his side and then and
speaking of Sam well that he finally
gets to Castle black with with Gilly and
kind of tells the story to Maester Aemon
who wisely believes him and starts
writing all these messages to everybody
yeah with the raiment yeah very very
very interesting turn of events in terms
of how will this affect everyone will
people start to communicate with one of
another who's gonna believe it who's not
who's gonna see the threat who's not
stare that says Melisandre saying yeah
that's real and he's pretty much gonna
listen to anything she says yeah because
she's one moment wasn't killed avos and
another moment he's letting him live and
all because of what she's saying and
she's entirely running the show for him
I mean whatever she says at this point
seems to be going you know she's already
brought up previously that she felt that
the real threat was this from the north
she's already said that previously and
that Stannis is the key to solving the
problem he is the key to saving and it's
the funny thing too it's the second time
in the episode that you get the idea of
tens of thousands of lives versus one
right before it was with Tyrion like oh
well what's 12 I mean Serena time was 12
people a dinner table versus 10,000 and
her thing to what's this one boy versus
10,000 lives when do you think of Davos
saving Gendry I mean and this is the
this is that is the question right
because i think this key question and
this is the question of so many
interesting series's the one versus the
money and he said what's one bastard boy
versus the kingdom and he says
everything it's everything and so that's
basically to me it's just your point of
view you know is one life more important
than many is one active evil worth
saving ten thousand a million lives I
don't I I don't serve as well yeah I
don't think there is an answer but i
think is an age-old question that that
comes up all the time and just it's in
this show they do it very well I think
Davos is point of view
is yeah i mean it is and i think another
thing that's interesting is that I love
the line that Gendry says we're not even
people to you meaning the lowborn we're
not even people to you we're just 1
million ways to get what you want you
know and it's it's that idea of the
lowborn versus the highborn and who is
value and one thing that that Daenerys
believes is that everyone has value also
at Castle black we get to see Jon Snow
he's all injured and hurt because his
his ex-lover regret shot with arrows
that's one way to break up yeah um I
don't know fury yeah I had incorrectly
um assumed last week that that that
brain had gotten into his mind and
that's why he ran away but I guess he
did it on his own which I don't know I
just felt that was kind of out of
character for him both of them are so
totally who they are right so I love
that he's like I know one thing I love
you and you love me but at the end of
the day he's he's got to be him you know
like he's got to be the man that he is
and he's gotta stick to what he believes
in and that means going back and she's
got to be the woman that she is and
stick with to what she knows and that
means shooting him with arrows you know
I wonder i'm wondering if part of her
love kept the arrow from going into any
vital organs yeah i feel like it was
just more of like a punch yeah exactly
so like for a while that was like a
wildling pumpkin the shows are like man
you hurt me is she really gonna kill it
yeah like she just wants to physically
hurt him back yeah I let him know i feel
like if she really really wanted to kill
him she could have yeah so King's
Landing which we didn't get a C in last
episode honestly I love all and some
people say it's boring the King's
Landing stuff i love it i love you i
love all the politics and all the
subtext of what people say to each other
and the whole council meeting with with
Tywin Tyrion Cersei Paris I mean man
Jonas serve her her brother's head and
he would he would everyone is mine to
torment he's just so hateful I know him
so much he's one of those
% evil one hundred percent of all just
Oh God why are you the way you are
Joffrey you know but I love again the
scene because they kind of did this
before but this was another example of
time when kind of like saying no no no a
little boy you may you may be the king
but I'm really the king yeah I think
it's it and I love his look to him like
yeah really I test me test me do it I
beg you I yeah I was you know and I
think that that's the thing is like what
you learn is that power isn't always
what it seems to me Tywin understands
real power and he's been yield wielding
it for a long long time it is
fascinating to me King's Landing because
of the political sort of nature of it
which is one of the things that I like
about the show if you look at a
character like Varys think of how much
our perception of various has changed
over the last four years in that scene
with Shay all of a sudden and we've seen
this a little bit this season and that's
what I'm saying about nobody being
purely evil Melisandre their mamas than
you think this one's really got the
greater good in mind well yeah if she's
saying oh we need to stop this uncommon
threat then you're like oh well that's
actually a good thing right and the same
thing with Ferris because he's like he
he says about Tyrion this is one of the
few people that really can do good for
the realm and you list the reasons why
you know and one of those reasons
circling back to another theme is he's
got the name for it yes you know the
mind in the name and you see these
people behind the people pulling the
strings and you think maybe Varys it's
that goat circling back to that chaos
the two sides of chaos speech with he
and little finger it really does have
the good of the realm in mind you know I
think it's fascinating the way they've
been able to construct these characters
that your perception of them shifts and
changes so much he did you know talked
to Shay and like try to convince her to
leave but you know she kind of threw
down the gauntlet gauntlet so instead
I'm gonna stay here which you know what
I'm thinking is just more than actress
than the character
I just don't like mm-hmm because I think
if that was a different actress that
played that same scene i think i would
have liked it a lot better I kind of had
mixed feelings about that scene because
I thought listen take the money and run
I mean let you've already rejected the
offer Tyrion mates you to set you up you
you don't like being his wife's
handmaiden and there's no future for you
here and he's told you that your
presence here puts Therrien in danger so
why I mean at that point take the
diamonds and go you're doing good for
yourself and for him yeah if she truly
loves him then she you know she might
consider like at least trying to keep
him out of danger I mean at that point
it becomes not a noble act but kind of a
very selfishly stubborn act and you're
just kind of like I'll get you you know
I really don't understand your choices I
don't think I dislike her quite the way
lot of people do like me really um but
at that point I'm like what is I don't
understand what planet you think you're
on but it but I think it's this I think
that one of the things that the show is
trying to bring home is this idea of
some sense of a galit Arianism like why
should I be unequal you know that kind
of question keeps coming up like why
should one person be more or less equal
than the other even with Sam you know I
am the guardian of all the men in the
realms that means her to write so I get
that also in that specific situation
you're done go take those diamonds that
scene between i love the seen some of my
favorite scenes are Tyrion and Cersei
they have such great chemistry they're
good friends in real life and maybe
that's what acting is it's so high I
know it's like what everybody wants to
be able to achieve yeah what the two of
them have together but what I think is
great is that in that moment again like
whenever search they sort of talks about
our children is when you really see
there is she dropped truth yeah tonight
it was like no I'm not happy but I would
have been dead if it wasn't for my
children yes even Joffrey and
knowledge is a monster but saying when
he was a baby he was lovely it's a lie
that I should have known and even
joffrey today can't take that figured I
had away and that's I don't know like
that that feeling she had me is like
help shape who who Joffe is yeah oh sure
well I'm sure I mean if you've seen any
of her motherly awful um she is who she
is you know and she's a Lannister and
she's douchiest that the other person
that she had that's her person has just
come back to her Jamie yeah I i liked it
was interestingly again like time
linearly that things move around but
that moment of her seeing him and is she
gonna accept him or reject him now that
he sort of been beaten down lost a hand
you know what do you know don't know but
you know it's weird because they are
brothers and we know their relationship
so it's weird cuz you're like all
they're back together and then you're
like wait oh wait oh that right yeah
exactly good oh but yeah I don't know
that's I did like to see that they
finally got Jamie back to King's Landing
I mean what happened to Brandon but you
but that's what I'm saying too is like
your perception of that even shifts over
time because you not that I kind of
donut condone incest by any stretch of
the imagination but she's so lonely you
know like she's just so totally lonely
like Robert never loved her um he
reviled her in many ways he mocked her I
mean all she's ever known as power her
father never loved her not really really
you know like the only person that's
really really loved her as Jamie I mean
look at her kid you know oh yeah and
speaking of her father with that Tywin
seeing with Tyrion was also also great
about having him stay behind because
Tywin does acknowledge that Turing has a
great mind and so he kind of wants to
talk to him and see how things how he
thinks about the whole you know red
wedding situation how he coordinated it
and and what you know Tywin has a little
different perspective he has a
perspective we do this
believably heinous crime or this heinous
thing and people will be afraid of us
antarians perspective is no you do that
let heinous thing people are gonna
remember and they're gonna come get you
yeah and and I think there are so many
beautiful lines tonight um you know
every how long does this last sister say
until we're dull with all our enemies
yeah but every time we deal with one we
make two more I guess it's gonna last a
long time then you know and it's Tyrion
I mean Danny's perspective is is
although I mean listen again nobody's
all good Danny's out like raising cities
and she's a lot of being people are
being killed in her name setting things
on fire setting people on fire with her
dragons but um you know her perspective
is obviously closer in line with Tyrians
in a sense of like you're better off
winning their love and their loyalty
than having them fear you in the end
you'll be better off that way now how
that's all gonna play out I don't know
you know in different ways over the
seasons but you know it's just
interesting because Tywin is so totally
convinced otherwise yeah and then he
also revealed that he wanted initially
to put him went earrings warm put him
into the ocean just kill him basically
yeah i mean it's it's like it never
stops being painful you the thing is
you've heard Tywin's say these awful
things to Tyrion over and over it just
keeps getting worse and it just keeps
getting more painful and you think the
fact that he turned out to be the human
being that he is is like a miracle yeah
you know that he has the integrity that
he is and he has the honor that he does
is kind of a miracle considering what he
is grown up in one thing that I kind of
wanted to check in with you about is it
now that we're at the end of the season
and certainly the fantasy element has
elevated more and more and more oops in
the beginning certainly in this season
there's a high level of magic going on
and that even came up with Stannis and
Melisandre well did the blood do you
think her blood spell was responsible
for Rob's death I don't think so I don't
know I just like when davo said it's
like this is you know
all these kids are finding each other to
tell each other something like that's
bound to happen what is a causal and
what is not what is what is the magic
created and what is it not i mean the
magics purely clearly present right but
like what school is like you don't know
what to believe happy believe in the
dragons dragons that's what I believe in
I mean that's real right yeah well we
see him I'm you know they fly around and
blow fire and kill people and yeah so
and I think part of that whole Danny
thing to bring it back to the beginning
of the belief in this religious type
figure is they see the Dragons so the
dragons are something people haven't
seen it hundreds of years and so they're
kind of kind of a myth and now they
finally see some live and they see who's
controlling well I think that from you
the the cool and interesting thing about
the show is that oftentimes when
something like magic is introduced it's
easy it just means boom magic I can do
that now suddenly things are really easy
what's cool about Game of Thrones is
that it does not mean that you know and
it does not mean you automatically win
and it doesn't mean you automatically
have all the power in fact sometimes
magic makes things harder right because
bran has these incredible abilities
right that are mystical and and I guess
in some ways magicals or though that's
intertwined but look at what he had to
suffer to get it yeah and look at what
he's asking to do because of it going
right into the heart of the Beast going
right into danger yeah there's always a
price to pay for that like you either
gotta kill someone that you shouldn't be
killing or sacrifice something part of
you yourself or something Your Honor
anything like that and and in order to
get some of that magic you know yeah so
that's what I like about it because even
though it's magical it's still complex
yeah anyway looking forward to next
season yes I am I'm so sad that we have
to wait ten months I don't know what I'm
gonna do I think I probably win one of
these months I'm just gonna marathon
season one two and three but I'm so
looking forward to season four
I am really really looking forward to
season for it man there's so much good
stuff in store I'm excited to see what
they keep what they change and how they
do it because that's one of the
interesting things for me about watching
the show so if you guys want to see our
season 4 reviews next year when the
season starts make sure you subscribe to
our new think hero channel that's a
think hero pro this is going to be the
last review on this think hero TV
channel so and you can always a check
out Roth on IGN you can find my work on
ign.com every single day you can follow
me on twitter at my name at Roth cornet
yeah and i'm on twitter as well that's
at think here oh and you can find our
Facebook page that's a big hero fans